- [Voiceover] Human, are you awake?
(barking)
- Oh, hello.
- [Voiceover] You're awake!
I love you, I love you, I love you
- Oh my God, Roxi.
- [Voiceover] I love you, oh.
- Do you wanna go on a walk?
- [Voiceover] Yes! Of
course I wanna go on a walk.
- Okay, let's go on a walk.
- [Voiceover] What are you sayin', human?
Here we go.
There's no time for that.
There's no time, you don't need shoes.
Let's go, I don't wear any shoes,
what are those?
Ahh, yes.
The open air.
What is that?
(barking)
I will save you, human.
Get outta here, you big piece of metal.
Goodbye.
(barking)
Yeah, I told that.
- Come on, let's go.
- [Voiceover] Alright,
here we go, here we go.
(panting)
- Let's take your leash off.
- [Voiceover] (gasp) Yes, I can run.
I am free.
I am free as a bird.
Oh, this is the best.
Gotta poop.
Which way is the
gravitational force pulling?
Oh yes, this is it.
Nothing like some eye
contact while you're poopin'.
- Good poops, baby.
- [Voiceover] Oh, this guy's a cutie.
I'm gonna set it up for human.
- Hey, hey there you.
- No, sorry. This is Roxi.
- No, its no problem.
Hey Roxi.
- [Voiceover] Oh yeah.
- Aww.
- Yeah.
- [Voiceover] She'll thank me later.
- Hi.
- I'm Ben.
- Shantelle.
- [Voiceover] Oh, what a gorgeous day.
Who's this?
Are you my new best friend?
Hi.
Wait, I love you.
I wanna play with her, human.
What're you doin'?
- Come on.
- [Voiceover] Okay, fine.
- Roxi, you want a treat?
- [Voiceover] Uh, of
course I want a treat.
Is that even a question?
- Good job, baby.
- [Voiceover] Wait, no,
where are you going?
- Alright baby, I'll
see you tonight, okay?
Be good.
- [Voiceover] Please don't leave.
Human.
Please, human.
No, can I come with you?
Oh, man, I almost made it that time.
(barking)
Oh, but she left the door open.
Yes, this is my shot.
Oh, this looks so, yes.
Oh, and her shoes?
Oh these are great.
These look so yummy.
And the biggest water
bowl in the universe.
I just want, just a little sip.
- Oh, hello.
- [Voiceover] She's home, human.
You're home.
- Hi, baby.
- [Voiceover] Never leave me again.
- Oh yes.
- [Voiceover] I missed you so much,
I promise I was a good girl
except for the water bowl,
and eating your shoes,
and going through the trash.
- Alright.
- [Voiceover] Never leave again.